next up the guardian is reporting that
we've reached a new era in our culture
we are living in the time of goblin mode
okay let me explain goblin mode is
something we all have and we can turn it
on and we can turn it off it describes
those in times when you completely give
in to your most goblinish qualities and
you enjoy it because it heals your soul
for example maybe you make a nacho tray
fit for a family and eat the entire
thing alone while binge watching emily
and paris season two yeah been there
maybe you eat oreos over the sink in the
dark in your underwear
and maybe
maybe you crawl into the same sweats
every night having no idea if you've
ever washed them
uh
uh drew i wash mine yeah
you do
um so goblin mode yes do you goblin well
i've been known to gobbling up some
doritos i know that's for sure you know
but it's just about being like
gluttonous and what is the most
gluttonous thing you do
i like to spread uh some butter on
raisin toast
yes
sunflower seed butter yeah on raisin
toast um this isn't at night i don't
even turn on the lights i can do it in
the dark
um and and then i put that in a bowl and
then i pour just a little bit of like
popcorn in the bowl with some hot sauce
i crawl back in the bed and i eat until
i fall asleep
that sounds so good i'm going to name it
the zaynab and i'm going to do it
tonight
count me into
the perfect snack
i love that all right next up we love to
try out the latest trends here at the
desk and today we've got the hottest new
snack on tick tock we have a drew's
review
okay so
we love to get suggestions from viewers
on what we should try and today's pick
comes from hugh connolly thank you hugh
he asked us to try
mashed potato chips okay this is what's
happening on tick tock it's exactly what
you think it is apparently you boil
potato chips
out of the bag and then mash them into a
paste
and then you add in milk butter or cream
and salt and pepper to taste i think it
sounds like a goblin oh yeah right yeah
um okay so sorry i'm salivating um
so this is remember like idaho spuds and
potato buds oh my god the boxed potato i
didn't know mashed potatoes came from an
actual potato until i was like 20. i
thought it just was out of the box so
this it feels like kind of a i don't
know some version of that yeah is that
it i want it to be really good right
well one two three okay okay ready all
right q
oh
yeah y'all don't like it
no we love it
we get mad when we like it because then
it's like oh no now it's going to be a
thing yeah oh this sucks okay
now
now this is gonna haunt my dreams you
know what i mean you know would be
really go great with
um a slice of raisin toast and a little
popcorn
i thought you were gonna say a
thanksgiving dinner oh that too
this is good
i was watching jlo before bed last night
and hustlers
i feel like i could just watch jlo and
eat this and find my happy place in life
do you think
do you think j lo eats this
no i i i i maybe it's like a treat and a
bite and i i don't know you know well
you know even jennifer aniston who i
love remember she eats the one eminem
and the one potato chip that but that's
what they what they get for it they look
like adonis sculpture yeah you know what
you get from like my lifestyle
that
[Applause]
so
you know
all right
so it's time to rate it what do we think
of this out of five stars what do you
give it you notice how i dip the chip in
the chip yeah i see how you know
you know what i would give it um
i would give it a 4.5 is that okay yeah
that's got it yeah
drew
i'll give it a 4.52 i'm with zainab yeah
that's good i'm going to give it away
because i'm going to eat it
get it away from me thank you
[Applause]
i love you
i love your story about your dad that's
so meaningful thank you for sharing that
with us live your dreams honor your
heritage
thank you zainab for that wisdom you
dropped on us
[Music]